All right.
So there's
going to be a couple key
ideas to make this work.
And one of them is the simulation lemma.
The idea of the simulation
lemma is that if we have
a pretty good estimate of the real MDP,
then optimizing our rewards in that
estimate is going to be
pretty good in the real MDP.
>> This is a lemma about simulations,
not a simulation about a lemma.
>> That's right.
It's not a simulated lemma.
It's a lemma about simulation, right?
And so the idea is that
we've got transitions and
rewards that are off by alpha or
less, and
we want to think about what happens
if we adopt some policy pi.
Any policy pi.
We want to compare the value we get for
following pi in MDP 1.
That has transition function T1 and
reward function R1,
to the value that we get, return that
we get for following policy pi in
mdp V2 which has transition
function T2 and reward function R2.
>> Okay.
>> And if those are going to be near
each other given that T1 is near T2 and
R1 is near R2,
then that's going to give us the ability
to have accurate simulations, right.
We can use our model of
the MVP to stimulate.
What's going to happen in the real MVP.
And just to be concrete, this is what I
mean by the transition functions, reward
functions not being too different,
than we have this value alpha.
And if we take the maximum over all
state action x state triples, that
the probability assigned by transition
function T1 and the probability assigned
by transaction function T2 are not
different by more than alpha.
And, same thing with the rewards.
>> So that's a little weird.
>> How so?
>> Well, because the transition model
is probability, so
that can't ever be off by more than one.
>> Sure.
>> And the rewards can be gigantic
numbers that can be off by billions.
>> Sure.
>> Billions and billions.
So, it just seems a little weird.
>> You feel like it should
be two different alphas.
Yeah, alpha T and
alpha R, but maybe not.
>> Yeah, I mean I didn't want
to proliferate variables
when we didn't really need to,
but you're right.
The scale of these could
be very different.
A lot of times in the proofs that
people use for these kinds of MBPs.
They first assume that rewards are all
in the range zero to one, also.
It doesn't change the fact that you
still might want a different alpha for
the two cases, but it does at least get
the scale More approximately correctly.
>> Okay, so
then without loss of generality,
assume that all your rewards
are between minus one and one.
>> Or zero and one.
Why not?
Because it's all the same MDP.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, they look more
like probabilities or something.
>> Okay, cool.
So,
without loss of generality assume that
your rewards are between zero and
one and your transition probabilities
which Would have to be here between
zero and one so that we can use the same
alpha and everything kind of works out.
>> Yeah.
Again,
it still might be worth
having different alphas.
But yeah, you're right.
Again, it puts us in
the right ball park.
>> Okay.
So this is a ball park simulation.
I'm perfectly fine with that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now we're out of the ballpark.
So that's either a vacuum cleaner or
a metal detector,
or it's a gigantic baseball
being knocked out of a park.
>> It was supposed to be a ballpark,
but it looks to me more like
some kind of terrible
>> Cruel alien.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I
>> With
>> I don't know.
>> Head issues.
>> Anyway,
the point is that, it's.it's alpha
close to a reasonable pictures.
>> And that's alpha.
Okay.